what does this mean for folks back in
Korea and what does this says
it's not just in Korea but I think for
all creators and talent or people who
are currently doing it or aspiring
creators and talent all around the world
who do not speak English I feel like we
were lucky enough to approve or show
that what you create can impact the
world it can impact even United U.S
culture it can become mainstream and I
truly hope that we were able to show
that kind of potential and possibility
so that more people could dream and
think of Greater opportunity cities I
feel like they are all going to be very
happy for our wins and I'm sure that
this was due to a lot of their support
as well you made history tonight
[Music]
I am extremely grateful I never in my
wildest dreams thought this day would
come and when actually my name was
called out I had to think once again
because I didn't think it was really my
name
I was like oh it's my name
what does that mean though to you to
know that you are in the history books
for the first you know non-english
speaking show to win you know the big
acting Awards the big Awards on Emmy
night it is
foreign
the way we portray emotions and our
thoughts it's not only through language
there are a lot of things that are
outside of language that we use to
express these things so I feel like that
having acted and performed with a
different kind of language and having
that Resolute and resonate with so many
people around the world it's such a huge
meaning to me personally and I hope and
I believe that it is also meaningful to
other actors as well were you hanging
out tonight and then What's it gonna be
like when you go back home
we'll drink right
Ah that's the universal language ursulin
we will drink
okay so you have this massive hit that
people love now you have to go into
season two is there pressure how do you
top it what do you do
I mean I have I have a JJ Lee so I'm in
season two I'm working on it now I'm
working on the script and I believe I
have better script than season one wow
okay okay we heard that he said it with
his chest
I might regret this but I never heard
that
oh all right well guess what we'll see
you here next year then there we go
season two like in two years two years
okay